[Music]
all right today's question comes from
jennifer in kansas
my husband is 100 sure that the world
will end soon or martial law will take
effect and money will not hold any value
because of this he will not save he has
business and personal credit card debt
he has zero savings and spends his money
as fast as he makes it he's up to date
on his payments but has no interest in
paying them off so he can start saving i
am currently saving as much as possible
and will have the last of my debt paid
off later this year
i have life insurance in place for all
of us and a 401k he will also be able to
draw my pension at my old job if i
should pass before he does i feel like
i'm the only one preparing for our
future and honestly it's hurtful
i don't know how to get through to him
that even though the world may end in
our lifetime we should still be
responsible with our money and be
prepared
how can i get through to him
dave
how can she get through to him um
well i mean
the extreme way you've explained him
this is not somebody who's merely a
prepper this is not someone who is
merely
feels like that the culture is uh
deteriorating this guy is so sure
that he's so paranoid that that the
whole thing is going to crash down that
he according to you this according to
jennifer that he is doing nothing
responsible
uh he's just living his life today now
or
he's a complete liar
and this is his excuse for being a
freaking child right
um and doing whatever he wants to do
either way this guy is
exercising
at a level of mental illness that is
pretty extreme right
this is a paranoia situation or it's a
depression that is
lapsed into i i literally can't think
through
to to tomorrow so i'm just living for
the next five minutes the next 10
minutes yeah and um i'll create this
narrative and i will find some websites
that will back up my narrative there's
there's a thousand of these conspiracies
millions of them websites and
you know all you gotta do is watch the
news and it makes them all come true
that's exactly right and uh but they're
not you know so um
let me just tell you that
the world has problems
and uh the world has always had problems
100 of the time and uh but the uh
percentage likelihood of martial law and
of you losing all of your personal
assets coming together in your lifetime
is so small that to believe that 100
percent to the point that it affects
your behavior where you do nothing
responsible for your family is called
paranoia that is a mental illness level
this is not merely we have a
disagreement about how life works this
is you are your husband is mentally ill
and so let me am i wrong no and in fact
here
dave um what i had a seizure on life
when um i had you and i've talked about
this i had mapped out in a very um
beautiful mind kind of way
where this data point led to this one
and this one and i wasn't well and i had
come to figure out that oh the housing
market was going to recollapse and they
were going to have to nationalize i had
created this whole world and so i was
going to cash out this and go do this
and i'd never forget sitting with the
cfo of a 200 million company i sat down
explain what i was about to do with my
retirement i was going to cash it out
because money's not gonna and i remember
him gently looking at me and saying i
don't really understand this please
don't do this and i left that meeting
and i thought he didn't see it he didn't
get it and i'm a guy that barely knows
how to work a spreadsheet right so
here's the thing
when somebody is in this position the
data and facts don't help a lot
but somebody in this position needs to
go get help yeah i had to go sit down
with somebody and say i'm i'm seeing the
world different than everyone around me
who loves me i need some help yeah and
you're right the world's got problems it
does um one of my close friends gave me
a quote that has stuck with me forever
and he said john i got a lot of plans
but i don't have a meteorite plan if a
meteorite hits us i will deal with that
on that day
and the idea that suddenly money's going
to hold no value and tanks are going to
roll on every street
if that happens i'll deal with that on
that day and until then i'm going to be
responsible and care for my wife who
feels like she's drowning over here by
herself and we're going to go from there
yeah he's not going to give in to that
because it's futile right
it's just futile
yeah there there's yeah he he needs to
need help he needs to see a counselor
yeah he needs help so jennifer no amount
of you sitting down trying to explain
stuff to him is going to how can i get
through to him you can't you cannot you
can't because his brain is not
functioning properly right
if somebody in his life that he is
someone that he trusts that would sit
down with him and say hey let's go talk
to somebody great if you say hey i'm
going to go talk to someone i'd love you
to join me to be great uh but he needs
to get some help yeah i don't by the way
he he doesn't think he needs help so
that's probably gonna be very difficult
so but just
the point is is that this is not he
isn't you're not gonna solve this riddle
you don't have the tool set i did have a
friend that came and spoke truth to me
my wife spoke truth to me and i wasn't
this bad um
but uh that was helpful it was two
people that i trusted and i said i'm
gonna go talk to somebody yeah well and
i think you might get some guidance from
a good counselor if you were seeing one
on how to deal with this situation
because here's what's ultimately going
to happen okay having dealt with couples
in your situation for 30 years
one of two things is going to occur
and there's really not much middle
ground there's not a third thing it's
one of two
he is going to recognize this get some
help and gradually over time get better
and your lives are going to get better
and get more normalized and you're going
to be able to aim at a future and build
a build some wealth and get out of debt
and start living reasonably
and you're going to start taking some
incremental not instantaneous but some
incremental steps in that direction
which will give you hope
if that does not occur
100 of the time at some point you are
going to boil over
a switch is going to flip
and you're gonna be done
and there's there's gonna be no talking
you back
because when ladies in particular
are done
after holding their breath for a decade
or for
three years or for whatever when they're
done
you can't switch them back on you can't
switch them back into love mode it's
you're in resentment and that's actually
it's over that's right it's over and uh
because they they've
they reached that i've had it moment and
it's there they really have had it and
they're really gone and so don't let
that happen to you
uh it's going to happen to you if you
don't control the process now you can
control the process and you say okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna give him this
much time i'm gonna try these five
things to encourage him at that point
i'm gonna call this because this
relation i can't be married to a crazy
person
and he is mentally ill darling he's
mentally ill we just diagnosed it um
dave
some of this feels like a
self-fulfilling prophecy to me
that if you get enough people saying
well
money's going to be of no value so let's
just blow it all and run up all of our
debts and go but
that that's the quickest way for money
to have some serious problems right is
that fair i don't know enough about
monetary policy that it just feels like
you're we're starting to see a what
rabbi lapin says he says money is not
actual it's spiritual
so when i give you a hundred dollar bill
the actual paper is not worth a hundred
dollars right it's a spiritual
transaction of trust
and so when i give you a hundred dollar
bill you accept that hundred dollar bill
for 100 in goods and services or you get
eyes get big and you say thank you or
whatever it is because you trust that
you can take that and do something with
it
and so what you're saying is and it's a
valid point that if enough people lose
that trust
then the money is destroyed
or if enough people act so ridiculously
i mean if you lose if if 90 of people
lose trust in
the money
the money is no longer currency there
you go there's no current to it right so
i mean i've got some confederate money
from the before the civil war
yeah you know what you can buy with that
nothing right there's no trust
association we have a vested interest in
saying hey instead of running from this
and acting like children let's lock back
and try to get some let's let's build
let's build civilization together good
grief yes